انه موعد اجتماع التحرير في اذاعه
موزاييكه التونسيه الخاصه
خليفه
لنشر خبر حصريا يتعلق بتفكيك خليه ارهابي
تم استدعائه من فرقه
بتونس العاصمه
وتم يعني التحري معي لكشف عن المصادر انا
احترام لشرف المهنه واحترام المرسوم 115
مصادر سنه 2011 مناظر للحريه الصحافه
واتباعه والنشر رفضت بالكشف عن المصدر
وعلى حائط قاعه التحرير علي قلبي الاذاعه
بما في ذلك الفصل السابع
لكن المرسوم 54 المؤرخ في الثالث عشر من
سبتمبر 2022 يرمي بالحريات عرض الحائط
وسيله جديده للضغط على وسائل الاعلام بحسب
نائبه رئيس النقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين
التونسيين
الثانوي
في المعتدين اليوم هيئه الانتخابات تراسل
المؤسسات الاعلاميه والصحفيين وتهددهم
بالمرسوم 54 وتهددهم بالنيابه العموميه
لمجرد نقديهم لاداء الهيئه خلال هذه
المسار
مع السلامه داخل هذا البيت في قلبك تونس
يوجد مقر موقع نوال رئيس تحرير ايمن رزقي
يحذر من مخاطر المرسوم الجديد فهو لا
يستهدفه الصحفيين فحسب
الجميع في تونس ليس سيف مسلط على الصحفيين
فقط هو مسلط على كل من له كلمه حره على كل
من له صفحه في مساء التواصل الاجتماعي
يعني ااه تقريبا بدا اليوم نحس انه هناك
هذا المرسوم نجح في خلق مناخ من الخوف
بالنسبه لي انه ما زال للعوده لمربعي
تكميم بل المعركه الحريه ستتواصلونها
[موسيقى]
في الحديقه يستعد الموقع الاعتداني نقاش
المجتمعيه عن الانتخابات التشريعيه لن
يروق
لسلطه الحكيمه